ces jours d'entraînement à distance pour
rené 80 à 90 minutes d'exercices
exigeant avec un groupe d'aînés qui vu
vieillir dans la dignité
j'ai gagné plus de club alain ce set
empêche de tomber cette tempête doit de
faire mal mais rené et les aînés de ce
programme baptisé web x font partie
d'une minorité
pour moi la bombe à retardement aller
maintenant c'est ce qu'ils vont se dés
confiné qu'ont perdu de la condition
physique avant la pandémie 60 à 70% des
ennemis étaient considérés inactif ce
qui veut dire qu'ils bougeaient moins de
trois heures par semaine et les
confinements honte aggravait le problème
c'est à peu près dix minutes de marche
de moins par journée ce qui ne paraît
pas énorme mais calculée au bout ça fait
soixante dix minutes
et donc c'est ça qui est un appât
d'abord la perte de masse musculaire
beaucoup plus rapide que chez les plus
jeunes
de façon générale ce déclin est assez
important il est quasiment deux fois
plus à trois fois plus chez la personne
âgée
la pandémie frappe donc la santé
physique et cognitive des aînés -
équilibre perte de masse musculaire père
de mobilité ce qu'on vaut beaucoup plus
de gens aussi qui vont à l'urgence avec
des chutes puis avec des fractures
parce qu'ils y sont ils sont des
conditionné et pour nos aînés les
dommages pourraient être permanent ils
en ont perdu à cause de ce déclin et ils
ne récupéreront pas alors qu'une
personne jeune qui va avoir décliné va
récupérer son niveau initial mais le
réseau de la santé ne baisse pas les
bras et attaque le problème de francs on
intègre de plus en plus l'exercice dans
les établissements
gaétane gauthier audet a recommencé à
marcher
grâce à l'exercice prescrits après une
chirurgie la marche est puis ensuite la
cades qui est chez elle elle a gardé sa
joie de vivre et veut retourner à son
chalet dans charlevoix
mais la pandémie a pourtant touché la
santé mentale de bien des aînés il ya
plusieurs personnes plus âgées qui ont
eu un jean d'apathie qui est apparu
parce que moins ils ont été actifs - en
sont capables d'en faire
puis moins ils ont le goût d'en faire
aussi je sais ce qui est le plus
inquiétant
rené encourage les autres ennemis à
bouger pour maintenir la flamme l'argile
même le surpoids devrait pas arrêter de
faire ça avec le déconfinement qui
s'amorce le groupe s'entraînera à
nouveau dans un parc dès juillet
comme pour la relance des chirurgies
reprendre l'activité physique chez les
personnes âgées sera un défi majeur au
cours des prochains mois ici david
gêne-t-il et radio canada montréal